[Musique]
madame monsieur bonsoir
d'abord je voudrais remercier agrosup
dijon d'avoir organisé ce têt dicks qui
en soi est déjà une rupture
toute l'équipe organisatrice julie chloé
etc pour leur travail extraordinaire est
tellement sympathique qui nous change
des congrès internationaux et qui vont
effectivement provoquer ce qu'on appelle
en anglais des fraîches à dieuze et on
vient d'en avoir une
avec de l'eau fraîche une fraîche à
dieuze alors quand ils m'ont demandé de
venir de toulouse la plus belle ville
aéronautique d'europe pour ne pas dire
plus de la galaxie et donc je me suis
posé la question je pourrais vous parler
de rupture franche comme par exemple la
volante
l'avion du futur puisque tous les avions
se ressemblent on travaille sur vraiment
l'avion du futur
ou alors la présente artificielle sur
laquelle nous travaillons pour les vols
de plus de deux ans est loin de la terre
mais j'ai préféré vous parlez d'une
rupture qui est déjà efficace depuis dix
ans et vous présenter une plateforme
petit peu comme ceux ce cercle qui porte
une dizaine de projets dont 7 sont déjà
opérationnels et trois sont en devenir
alors cette plateforme est une rupture
enfin qu'il fait rupture avec la rupture
en ce sens que nous en tant que
physicien des structures oui parce que
je suis physiciens des structures on
passe notre temps à rompre des
structures mais non pas pour les casser
mais pour voir ce qu'ils ont dans le
ventre pour faire de la science on casse
des avions pour qui ne cache jamais en
vol voilà pour faire simple et c'est pas
du tout une cassure que je vais vous
présenter mais au contraire un
rassemblement disciplinaire sa terre
c'est une rupture dans la tête une
rupture psychologique une rupture
universitaire lors ça c'est un monde
très compliqué sous l'égide de la très
belle université de toulouse qui est
université aussi belle que que celle de
dijon et dans laquelle j'ai le plaisir
d'être fou le professeur et directeur de
recherche et je viens en fait avec une
triple casquette alors la casquette de
professeur à supaéro sa selle en fille
voilà la casquette de directeur
scientifique de l'institut clément ader
qui est 1e r cnrs de 236 chercheurs qui
cassent des structures pas on fait pas
que ça mais on fait beaucoup de
mathématiques pour sécuriser les
structures c'est à dire leur garantir un
taux de survivabilité de l'ordre de 10 -
7 par heure de vol
enfin dans ses pâtures et celle inverse
un taux de létalité de 10 - 7 par heure
de vol
on avait bien compris et puis je viens
aussi parce que moi aussi je suis un
mouton noir figurez vous on m'appelle le
mouton noir parmi les blouses blanches
parce que je suis depuis cette année le
physicien du chu de toulouse
les anglais les américains plutôt me
disent c'est de tisser schiste monde
deux physiciens d'ailleurs c'est le même
mot pratiquement en anglais et donc la
rupture que je vais vous présenter
maintenant
en réalité c'est un pont qui nous
transforme petit à petit comme le montre
ce magnifique tableau alors pour ça il
faut partir de notre spécialité de
physiciens des structures nous sommes
des chasseurs d'entropie alors qu'est ce
que c'est que l'entropie l'entropie
c'est la flèche du temps c'est tout ce
qui fait que ben quand une plante
voilà une comparaison qu'on peut
utiliser ici quand une plante croit elle
croit c'est à dire que quelque part oui
elle évolue absolument elle regarde
devant je vous vois sourire genre
j'enfonce des portes ouvertes mais ça
aussi c'est l'entropie d'enfoncer des
portes ouvertes et donc c'est pas du
tout le désordre ça c'est boltzmann qui
vous en raconter ses histoires
moi je vous dis que l'entropie c'est une
partie de l'entropie l'été trois piliers
qui porte non notées çà on à 118
thésards et 49 hdr à clément ader
on en a 50 sur la thématique de
l'entropie statique c'est à dire les
rides de la structure nous on a des
rides ça donne beaucoup de charme
mais ça ne nous limitent pas notre
domaine de vol eh bien c'est exactement
comme ça le les structures avions
lanceur hélicoptère tout ce qu'il voit
et tout ce qui vole pas d'ailleurs le
tgv aussi il est certifié par mois
ensuite on à l'entropie dynamique à
l'entropie dynamique si vous voulez
voilà une sauce et le démonstrateur
universel des structures c'est la poutre
de galilée il s'est posé la question
devait former d'une poutre le le père
galiléo pied de la tour de piste et donc
quand on va faire travailler une
structure voyez il ya un échange
ethernet attention j'ai bien dit éternel
d'énergie cinétique et d'énergie
potentielles et puis il ya le côté
obscur de la force qui est la partie de
l'énergie qui n'est ni cinétique ni
potentiel qui va créer de
l'endommagement qui va créer quelque
chose qui n'est pas mécanique
voilà et ça ça nous intéresse beaucoup
j'ai quarante doctorants qui travaillent
sur ce sujet et puis ils vous échappe
pas que la structure travaille dans
l'atmosphère elle interagit avec le
reste du monde
au reste du monde ici c'est la poster ça
peut être la foudre par exemple quand un
avion se prend se prend un éclair le
coup de foudre ça existe aussi pour pour
les avions ça arrive pas souvent dans la
vie met un avion en général en moyenne
il a un coup de foudre dans sa vis à vis
d'un avion c'est 100 1000 heures de vol
et 25 années et donc
il a en général un ou deux coups de
foudre c'est un peu comme nous dans sa
vie et donc tout ça ça se modélise
mathématiquement puisque nous sommes
avant tout des matheux et donc nous
avons ce troisième sujet qui va nous
intéresser particulier ça marche comme
une fusée à trois étages cette affaire
là voyez la troisième étage là c'est le
multi physiques driving simulation ça
veut dire tout simplement la
modélisation de la structure la
mécanique dans le reste du monde
voilà et donc là dedans parmi le reste
du mondial et sciences du vivant et nous
avons une dizaine de doctorants
effectivement non et je vous présente
une dizaine de doctorants qui représente
les fameux 10 projets auxquels je vous
je faisais allusion qui travaillent sur
l'interaction avec le monde de la vie
alors ça j'ai pensé que ce serait
intéressant de vous en parler aussi dans
une école comme agrosup évidemment
puisque par définition
vous travaillez vous travaillez sur le
monde de refaire un tout petit peu de
physique de fizi pour comprendre que la
biologie c'est aussi de la physique la
biophysique n'aura plutôt parler de
biodynamiques alors c'est une nouvelle
discipline qui a qui émerge maintenant
qui existe depuis dix ans et dont nous
sommes porteurs à toulouse il était une
fois un réservoir de lanceurs voyez ça
c'est un réseau alors je vous le dis pas
du tout innocemment parce que le gars
qui travaillent sur ce réservoir de
lanceurs qu'elle réserve à ariane 6 eh
bien il a fait une thèse avec nous sur
l'oreille interne et le cnes de manière
très intelligente a jugé que les
compétences qu'il a acquise en matière
d'interaction flic structure dans
l'oreille interne et des fluides bizarre
très exotique des soli très exotique on
n'a pas la notice du constructeur n'ont
plus de l'oreille interne
mais rassurez-vous quand on a la notice
du constructeur s'est pas tellement
mieux parce qu'on n'y comprend pas
toujours
donc on a fait des modèles de ces
réseaux criminels bien fluide là dedans
qui s'appelle l'hydrogène qui a un
avenir fabuleux parce que je vous
signale que la solution du problème des
transports
on y travaille beaucoup 2 % des gaz à
effet de serre c'est l'aéronautique mais
on a un effet d'entraînement
énorme la solution c'est l'hydrogène on
vous raconte des histoires avec les
batteries
si vous voulez faire voler un avion un
airbus avec des batteries dix fois le
volume de cette pièce ne suffiraient pas
et je vous dis pas la masse et je vous
dis pas les produits chimiques qu'il
faudrait aussi donc si vous voulez pour
un avion léger jeu
pas pour un ulm je ne dis pas pour une
mobylette je ne dis pas mais pour un
airbus la solution c'est l'hydrogène
donc on travaille dessus par la
cryogénie et bien figurez vous que les
équations de ces coques là avec un
fluide de d'en bas c'est la même chose
qu'une cellule vivante vous prenez une
cellule vivante et bien c'est une coop
avec un fluide bizarre à l'intérieur des
inhomogénéités des de l'osmose savez ce
que c'est l'osmose bien dans l'hydrogène
ya quelque chose qu'on appelle la
fugacité qui est que vous vous en rendez
pas compte évidemment sur ce dessin mais
le fluide il passe à travers les
réservoirs et en plus il a ses modes
propres alors cédé mode un peu un peu
bizarre évidemment qu'ils sont une fois
de plus des mathématiques et donc les
médecins de montpellier d'abord puis de
plus de purpan à toulouse parce qu'ils
étaient un peu jaloux de montpellier
nous ont contactés pour que les
équations des réservoirs on les applique
à l'oreille interne au vestibule au
crâne à plein de choses et donc on
travaille actuellement sur les implants
cochléaires sur la compréhension des
sons à l'intérieur de la
vibro-acoustique ce qui se passe dans le
réservoir lanceur c'est exactement ce
qui se passe dans l'oreille interne
est ce que vous voyez là ça n'est pas le
réservoir ariane 5 c'est ce qu'on
appelle la membrane basilaire à membrane
basée en faire un peu d'anatomie dans
l'oreille vous avez un lit masson qui
s'appelle la cochlée qui est le siège de
l'audition il ya une membre à et
plusieurs membres amène à une chimie
kahn à une mécanique nous ce qui nous
intéresse c'est la membrane mécanique il
ya un organe là dedans qui s'appelle
l'organe de corti qu'est le siège de
l'audition nous avons nous avec une
alors on s'est associés quand même des
neurologues d'une petite université
américaine qui est à boston qui
s'appelle le m haïti et qui nous a qui
nous a prêté lors de leur disons leur
modèle neurologique du lien entre le
nystagmus auto immune cinétique de
l'oeil et les mesures à l'intérieur du
oui parce que dans la cochlée on peut
pas faire de me2 comment dirais-je de
mesures in vivo pour des raisons
évidentes si vous faites des mesures sur
le cadavre
malheureusement ça marche plus les clés
matériaux plus du tout l'âme donc la
seule façon de faire c'était de le faire
indirectement et le m haïti avait un
moyen de mesures par la neurologie le
faire donc on était obligé de s'associer
à eux
alors on a fait comme hello demain vous
savez musk il a réussi à faire son
lanceur parce que
a prêté son lanceur la nasa a prêté le
pad de lancement en europe allait
transmettre on fait du troc pour un
dollar symbolique en plus le fisc n'y
voit rien et donc mais oui et donc on a
fait pareil avec le m haïti nous ont
passé leur modèle neurologique nous on
aura passé leurs modèles mécaniques on a
publié ensemble et tout le monde était
content alors ben voilà c'est un exemple
c'est un exemple parmi d'autres de
modèles numériques que nous avons fait
mais je voudrais quand même maintenant
parce que je n'ai plus que huit minutes
devant moi je voudrais maintenant vous
parler un peu non pas du présent mais de
l'avenir alors le présent effectivement
on a créé une revue internationale oui
parce qu'on n'a rien pour publier quand
on est multidisciplinaire
c'est à dire quand on est à la fois
biologiste et physiciens ce qui semble
pourtant naturel bah on n'a pas de revue
de haut niveau donc est ce qu'on a fait
on en a créé une tout simplement on a
créé un certain nombre de structures par
exemple avec le commissariat à l'énergie
atomique qui travaillent sur le
scaphandre du futur eh bien on est servi
aussi pour les les exosquelettes pour
les enfants myopathes pour faire leur
éducation
on a on a un certain nombre de
programmes qui tourne comme ça mais je
voudrais vous en parlez d'un qui me
tient particulièrement à coeur parce que
ils concernent la biodynamique de
l'ensemble du système céphalo rachidien
depuis plus de dix ans on travaille avec
les astronautes sur les problèmes
d'atterrissage pour ça qu'on est présent
dans la cabine aurions soit dit au
passage ça n'est pas assez connue mais
les cabines qui sont fabriquées aux
états unis il ya des équipements
français dedans bon on le doit un petit
peu au médecin parce que comme le disait
mermoz tout décollage est facultatif
mais tout atterrissage est obligatoire
et donc un vol se terminera et oui un
vol se terminera toujours c'est comme la
vie d'ailleurs il ya toujours un début
et une fin et donc
le vol se terminera sur terre et nous on
a qualifié un certain nombre de modèles
du système céphalo rachidien sur
l'impact qui sert au soccer d'ailleurs
et qui sert aux passagers d'airbus je
vous signale que quand on qualifie le
risque vital mais parce que dans un
avion vous courrez des risques mais des
risques qui sont inférieurs aux risques
que vous courrez dans cette salle voilà
oui parce que dans cette salle
surtout avec moi vous courrez des
risques très importants que la salle
s'effondre que ya un tremblement de
terre que oui je dis toujours que ma
belle mère débarque etc mais quand vous
êtes dans l'avion vous courrez des
risques supplémentaires du fait que vous
êtes dans l'avion et des risques
négatifs qui sont soustraits du fait que
vous n'êtes plus dans cette salle et oui
et donc le jeu car c'est de la théorie
des jeux
on travaille sur les structures pour
faire en sorte que l'avion soit le lieu
le plus sûr de la terre c'est à dire que
quand on monte dedans
eh bien ils soient ils soient
parfaitement sûr alors dans ce cadre là
on avait bâti donc à un modèle céphalo
rachidien avec les masses modèle
effectifs d'interface les modes propre
si vous voulez du système céphalo
rachidien qu'on a utilisées donc pour un
certain nombre de sportifs de haut
niveau et puis pour les passagers de à
partir de l'a380 c'est nous qui l'avons
qualifié le modèle des passagers à bord
350 aussi bien sûr un petit peu avec
boeing aussi parce que quand boeing nous
propose des sous sous forme de contrat
on les accepte toujours et donc et donc
à partir de ces modèles là les médecins
sont venus nous voir parce qu'ils
s'intéressent non plus aux implants
électrique
aujourd'hui les enfants sourds profonds
alors c'est pour ça qu'on est
particulièrement motivé par cette
synergie biologie physique biophysique
biodynamique exactement c'est que les
implants qui les enfants pardon qui sont
implantés électriquement dans la cochlée
r c'est tout une affaire il ya 17
électrodes qu'on leur qu'on leur met
dans la cochlée c'est quelque chose de
douloureux et qui n'est pas naturel ce
qui serait naturel c'est la transmission
osseuse
alors pour ça on travaille sur le
contrôle prédictif généralisée du crâne
comme on le fait sur certains avions l'a
fait pour un boeing d'ailleurs qu'est le
l'osprey 1 qui le convertible
donc sur le contrôle actif des mots de
propre par contrôle prédictif généralisé
sur le crâne l'idée c'est de générer
dans la cochlée directement au bon
endroit
les vibrations qui beethoven ne
connaissait ça car tout le monde dit que
beethoven était sourd c'est un peu vrai
mais il avait une autre une surdité de
transmission mécanique il n'était pas
sourd profond ce sens que ça coquelet
fonctionnait encore et donc il avait sur
son piano erard vous fait monter une
lame métallique un peu comme cette règle
qui l'a fait glisser sur le cadre il
mordait la lame écho me taper comme un
sourd sur son piano et bien on dit qu'il
n'a jamais entendu la neuvième symphonie
ce n'est pas vrai il l'a entendue par la
conduction osseuse mais sans le contrôle
prédictif généralisée c'est à dire
extrêmement déformés donc nous on
travaille là dessus et on travaille en
particulier à faire un modèle
mathématique qui respecte plusieurs
choses bio inspirée
la première chose c'est trouver un méta
matériaux équivalents touché pour
l'hydrogène on a trouvé un matériau
équivalent en hydrogène liquide pour
faire les essais de vibrations dans mon
labo parce que faire des essais d'une
rationalité de rejets liquides dans mon
labo il n'en est pas question
d'abord parce que si ça explose tout le
monde est gelé sur place ensuite oui
enfin bon il ya un tas de ya un tas de
c'est un liquide absolument diabolique
fabuleusement intéressant mais mes
diabolique
donc on a trouvé un métamatériau très
compliqué comme le louvre les oiseaux
vous savez que les oiseaux qu'on
projette sur les structures c'est plus
des oiseaux c'est un matériau qu'on a
mis au point qu'à la même rhéologie on a
tout un tas de métamatériaux qui font la
même chose et donc on cherche un
métamatériau équivalent au cerveau pas
au cerveau pour penser un au cerveau
pour
euh simuler l'accidentologie et avoir un
modèle expérimental de l'accidentologie
et du coup ce sera un modèle qui servira
c'est la deuxième application chirurgien
car figurez-vous que les chirurgiens
c'est une chose qu'on a découvert
d'ailleurs dans les relations avec
pierre fabre car on a plusieurs
industriels qui nous aident pas que
l'aéronautique
il ya aussi un grand laboratoire
pharmaceutique je devais pas cité son
nom mais tant pis et donc j'ai pas cité
son et donc ils nous apprennent les
protocoles les protocoles humains et
donc j'ai appris avec un certain effroi
que les chirurgiens neurochirurgien
apprennent à opérer sur le terrain c'est
à dire oui c'est à dire pour faire
simple que pendant une opération il ya
le grand patron kellal le fou le
professeur qui est la viola qui opèrent
a le crâne ouvert
et puis il ya les lèvres qui est à côté
est tu prends le bistouri et on y va
quoi bon avec le méta matériaux on
pourra faire autrement oui parce que ça
marche pas sur un macchabée non plus à
et non et oui parce qu'on pourrait dire
il suffirait et non justement
donc qu'est ce qu'on propose un matériau
pour qu'ils puissent s'entraîner et
s'amuser et faire progresser la
chirurgie voilà alors il ya tout un tas
d'exemples comme ça qu'ils sont en train
de se monter donc nous avons sept
programmes qui fonctionnent trois qui
sont en cours de montage
mais je vous donne un scoop dans la
minute qui me restent toujours atterrir
sur le seuil de piste c'est la place
dans la minute qui me reste je vous
donne un scoop c'est que madame carole
delga qui est la présidente de la région
qu'il faut s'appeler occitanie
maintenant c'est plus midi pyrénées
c'est occitanie vous avez raison c'est
comme airbus a change de nom tous les
huit jours et donc pas tous les jours
mais presque donc madame delga vient
inaugurer notre plateforme
mercredi et elle est dotée à la
naissance d'un capital qui vient de
l'europe
comme quoi l'europe a aussi du bon voilà
dont je n'ai pas le droit de vous donner
le montant avant mercredi
mais qui est compris entre 55 et 60
millions d'euros
je vous remercie de votre attention
[Applaudissements]